oh here we go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome welcome everybody to NBA bets
that you guys love I don't know about
y'all but I'm feeling good I'm feeling
good because you know why we finally
seen one go through the hooplash last
week I was about to say last year no is
this one here since oh this week oh yes
Tuesday bro I'm tripping MB I'm tripping
I was about to say last year I said it
last week and it ended up being hey I'm
all discombobulated because we haven't
won one in so long it was just like the
excitement I was gonna say act like
you've been there but we haven't
we haven't been there in a while but uh
how we feeling today my boy Ryan word is
it sources has told me that you are in
the lands of New England
that is true yes your sources are
correct I went to go to Boston
um I'm witnessing the end of the heat
today I needed to be in the building
needed to make sure the energy stays up
I talked a lot of last show about
how the Celtics were not done and we're
gonna come back uh and I intend on
backing it up I'm a man of my word so
I'm here to push the boys on
Ryan is in the land of New England to
push those boys on okmb I heard sources
are telling me you still in shy Town
winning first baskets money how we
feeling about uh tonight how we feeling
about our place tonight are you uh
are you talking Celtics heat yet are you
going away for that I'm gonna I'm gonna
wait I'm feeling good about the first
baskets but probably not gonna play it
tonight got some lineup changes I think
if you want to have some fun if Lowry
starts his odds are going to be pretty
high maybe just sprinkle them see what
happens but this can be an epic game man
there's a lot on the line tonight I'm
ready to go
right get a little hand race here Greg
uh I just wanted to shout out Darian
darian85 said uh give Ryan his credit
don't forget uh you know Darian knows
Daria remembers the Tatum best bet last
week Terry Terry remembers I said we
were gonna have a show today Terry I
love Gary I love Derek I'm so glad he's
here I'm ready
hey let's get a hand the hand bro that
was so funny hey let's welcome everybody
to the show though let's welcome
everybody to the show my name is Greg
iby to your left is the man we like to
call producer ride until you're right is
the man of the app
my boy I like to call him MB uh make
sure you guys drop your Best Bets for
tonight's game in the chat we are only
talking the only game that is on tonight
that is the heat taking on those Boston
Celtics Ryan I know you are in the
comments brother
I know you're in the chat I know you saw
my mandarians giving you some flowers
are they talking uh locks in the chat
right now
well well they are because Ritter jumped
in and said Michael block is tied for 87
right now for those who know I I picked
Michael block to miss the cut
um so that's good if only he was if only
he was longer he'd be the best golfer in
the world unfortunately that's not
always Body Works uh KJ Mullins is back
in here uh heat guy said oh Ryan I'm
back he's a nice win last game LOL
appreciate you again respect we're on
we're we're both hardcore for our sides
but uh all right definitely Gotta Give
Ryan because I cash out that Tatum 30
plus oh that's Paul Paul Tyne oh this is
uh this is a give Ryan love day guys I
don't know if you want me to read in the
chat I don't know
hey money line nice season Ryan so um
let me hop in this chat because Ryan's
just literally reading all Ryan
propaganda and I
if this is really Ryan propaganda in the
chatter is he just cycling through and
going and picking the ones that he he
wants to to blurb out but uh I'm in the
comments right now I'm in the comments
and I see J Money 4 says Caleb Martin 15
plus points I think that that might be a
lockety
Hey listen man Caleb Martin has been
balling but let's not forget we got we
got this thing to go through the hoop by
playing this conservative so if we're
gonna start with Caleb Martin I would
like to start at 10 points and not
actually MB MB you made a great point
you made a great point that I did not
address at the beginning of the show
last week
we made it easy on ourselves guys we
made it very easy on ourselves we were
picking heavy favorites in it and it
totaled up around even money uh
this week I said if it ain't broke we
saw we saw it hit last week if it ain't
broke I fix it let's do the same thing
right guys
yes sir I'll get it yeah
let's go we got Ryan's buy-in I'm like
let's go we won let's get to it it was
finally dude we did it we got Ryan's buy
it and I'm juice so MB said let's take a
look at 10 plus points for Caleb Martin
minus 550 is a great place to start I
think our first play last week was like
minus 2 000 or something so we're
already ahead of schedule
yes sir I think so Noah 42 in here is
saying if you're feeling ballsy take
Caleb 20 points nah Jalen Hopkins
no we're not feeling busy today I'm just
trying to win again so we're gonna stay
with 10 and let's find some more let's
see what else we can cook up
not feeling ballsy today no no no no no
uh let me hop back in the comments then
anything that's on your mind Ryan in B
talk if if not I'ma just hop in these
comments because
they're already dropped who was it who
was it somebody just dropped uh Grant
Williams 10 plus points which is uh uh
it was to know us a grant 10 plus points
grants at plus 190. so I don't want to
do that if we can get Grant if we can
get Grant Williams alt points which I
don't know if we can no I probably guess
no we can't man
that stinks all right well the next the
next one I saw was J Money for Tatum ten
boards but Packers 34-34 says eight
boards is a lock
Batman is grabbing so many rebounds in
this series like if nothing else I know
that the Celtics have been up and down
and kind of inconsistent that man has
been hitting the glass all post season
he has been a machine down there
he has been cleaning up his last his
last five against the Heat 11 10 13 7
and 14. that's a lot of rebounds man
doing
yeah
let's see what six is at no we can't
that's that's unpurchasable that's too
expensive what was the number I didn't
even see it minus 4 500. we can't that's
why not it's out of my price range it's
not in my budget it's not on my budget
it's not on my budget is that gonna do
anything for us it look at this
and what and what Earth is this a leg
Greg it's mine
you literally the parlay slip if that's
a leg
but what if we just bump it to six and a
half what like watch what this will do
watch watch it just let me do my magic
just let me just all right cook it let
me cook cook mine is 1600 oh I didn't
really do that much see
just throw it in there
either either one's gonna hit
I'm down with either yeah so then
what do we what do we think bowling
you're the final verdict yeah I say put
it at six and if we want to switch it up
a little later we can switch it up
all right there it is uh I I got bagel
and lotses in here Derek white 10 plus
he said is staring at his face
I don't know if he said that but
you did a good job of making that
politically correct shout out to bagel
and locks who probably knows better
why Greg is the man of the people he is
all over it
Derek
um
what about Five Points
no I think he scores I think he scores
10 points
um he's played really well lately I
think that you know I think over the
last I think here let me look 16 9 11 11
23. he's gonna need to have a big game
um and like you just don't know what
Jalen Brown's Gonna Give You on the wing
um he's starting now so he's getting
more minutes like 10 points seems like a
a good number for him and that gets us
into good territory now we're now we're
flying a little close to the Sun though
I don't know we might want to just make
it let's just make this a four leg
parlay because we're getting you know
we're getting real adventurous at this
minus 119 dude this is this is too high
I don't know what's going on I do like
the Derek white leg though like Gabe
Vincent's out today he's not gonna have
to put in that much work on I mean not
let's be real Derek white has been
putting in any work on defense
numbers but is it it'll be a lot less
tiresome on defense now uh that he
doesn't have that aside
um as much so I I liked Eric and you
know he's been hitting his shots he's
been he's been great for the Celtics on
the offensive end honestly so I I think
minus 240 is a good a good price for us
Jalen Hopkins is in the comments
giving us bad vibes saying Derek white
won't score 10 but you know what we do
here we turn bad vibes into Good Vibes
Ryan is our Celtics Insider he says
Derek White's gonna get it done I firmly
believe in Ryan uh can we have you gonna
say something yeah do we have Derek
white in the last parlay we just had him
to make a three or was that Mark uh we
took him out we took him out because
again he was out of our price range
that's true so if we're if I'm confident
in the 10 if we want to just check what
his threes are that he he had a three in
the first like two minutes of the game
so that cash real easy I don't know if
he's got a market for one three
but if it's minus 250 yeah
all right we'll leave it alone y'all
know who else is uh
who else we haven't talked about that's
been having an incredible series
what is that correct Williams Jimmy
Jimmy Butler
Jimmy Butler has been playing very well
we didn't have him in the last parlay
which was kind of surprising
he's gonna have to play probably his
best game of the playoffs tonight if
they exactly exactly and we're gonna get
into our sides and and picks for the
night a little later but that's as much
facts as I can give you if he doesn't
have a good game the Celtics have no
chance to win tonight
and I think
I think Jimmy Butler has a good game
today
you mean like 15 points tonight good
game and be your reading right between
the lines bro Jimmy Butler 20 plus is
calling our name I was literally gonna
say that I was literally just gonna say
that I promise you that's crazy okay so
so Ryan doesn't like it but I know why
because he needs the Celtics to win so
why don't we just throw Jason Tatum's 20
points in there and call this a day how
about it no what
both of them I'm talking about both of
them
both of them will score 20 points
nah it's good it's good I like both nah
I know I don't we don't need to add
another light because we're already at
plus monies plus 102. oh yeah you're
right
I'm I'm okay listen
it I hate the fact that I'm gonna have
to I'm gonna be in the stand somewhere
rooting for this like that's just what
is that this is good what are you guys
doing to me this is good torture well
actually Ryan will happen it was me and
Greg had a one-on-one and we were like
we're gonna wait to the last leg and
we're gonna throw in Jimmy Butler just
so we can piss Ryan off and make him
sweat it at the TD Garden
hey that's that's good content though
Ryan that's good content you sweating
Jimmy I don't I was
I want to win Greg I don't I and I want
to have a good time while I win my bet
okay miserable
[Music]
I was just gonna ask I was just gonna
ask you what your hypothetical number to
ruin your life tonight is and you just
said 45.
your life will be your life will be
ruined well before he gets to 45 so you
can be pissed off for the last 25 points
and be happy when he gets to 20. well
I'm gonna bet this so it doesn't really
like you know what I mean yeah I might
as well make money if he's gonna ruin my
life whatever
hey they're branding this parlay as the
no chance this loses even though we have
won once parlay uh
so you guys tail at your own risk are we
locking this in fellas how are we
feeling are we locking this in I did see
and I know Ryan might not like this but
labo 3000 did mention the heat alternate
spread I'm just saying I'm I'm just
saying I ain't you know I'm not saying
we got to put it in the parlay why would
we do that listen I'm I'm I'm always
down to shake the cage and Rattle and
rattle Ryan but I don't want anything to
do with an old spread especially
to you
Kate Mullins saying he all spread plus
uh Heath plus ten and a half which I
don't hate but the entire world is on
the heat
iffy you just said that you didn't want
to all spread but then no that's what
I'm saying
I'm saying like I'm not taking the 10
points I I oh I'm not using the spread
at all tonight no way I think it's gonna
be so close
yeah I don't know this is a weird one
for sure this is Ryan how are we feeling
bro give us a Vibe check what do you
think well I you know I I thought there
was like some level of trust between the
three of us here because I was like in
my head I'm like I could toss out
Celtics money line but I was like ah
they're not gonna really go for that and
now we're talking heat spread we're
talking heat money line it's just
where's the there's no there has to be
trust for this to work you know what I
mean listen I trust I trust that you're
gonna have a good time tonight but I'm
not necessarily sure the end of the
night is gonna go the way you want
to have a good time then
I don't know it's about the journey man
it's not about the results you can have
fun during the game
bowling the journey took me through
Connecticut the journey wasn't fun
nothing yeah right about the journey you
did travel miles and miles to your
destination today so if the Celtics
don't pull for you oh wait that would be
tough but it seems like it seems like
we're locking in this car
I think we're good in The Vibes that
we're locking in this parlay Ryan can
you do what you like to do best here and
that is the keywords
the keywords like to do
okay I don't know I don't know about all
that like
part can you please review the parlay
for the people
yes sir uh so we got Kayla Martin to
score 10 plus points Jason Tatum six
plus rebounds Derek white 10 plus points
and Jimmy Butler 20 plus points four
legs plus one zero two uh we're back in
the plus money territory the haters are
screenshot I didn't think we would do it
screenshot screenshot it screenshot it
there it is there it is if you guys if
you guys want to tailor parlay make sure
you head on over to FanDuel uh Ryan tell
the people what's happening if they go
on over to FanDuel and want to sign up
yeah so if you're new to FanDuel that
five dollars on
Celtics probably minus eight right
that's probably the smart thing to do
but you know do you do what you want to
do but you bet five dollars and you get
150 in bonus bets guaranteed over at
FanDuel so jump over do that butcher
fifty dollars
it's a lot of money yeah let's go
everybody likes free money man
that's a parlay
yes sir you know what I'm saying throw
150 on the leg get back a little money
money and you like it
it depends on what the light is I'm not
just gonna say yes
I'm not a yes man Greg I know what
you're talking about he's talking about
gb20 Plus in heat money line I don't
know come on come on you know the
players performance doubles that FanDuel
offering hey this could be money over
there it'd be money over here but hey
let's talk let's get let's get down to
the nitty gritty man let's talk Best
Bets I'm going first I'm going first and
um
I need everybody to get close get close
get close to your phones get close to
your computer screens because listen up
Eric Spoelstra
today
he was told that the heat was minus
eight or they were eight point uh
underdogs today he said he doesn't give
a last game Jimmy Butler said him
and the team they're gonna go drink
beers they're gonna go drink wine and
they're gonna go listen to country music
because they don't they don't care about
the loss
they didn't care about the loss in game
four so I'm here saying it I'm here
declaring Jimmy Butler in the Miami Heat
are putting the end to this series today
Eric sprocia said he doesn't give a
Jimmy Butler's drinking beer and wine he
does they don't care Ryan they just
don't get Vincent isn't planned they do
they do not care they don't care they
said today is the day Ryan traveled
miles and miles up to Boston to see his
team and that's exactly what's going to
happen
I got nothing to do with the heat money
line tonight how did I make it in there
you work with me you work with me and
you're gonna be at the game today so I
knew that and I'm just feel bad that
you're gonna have to be there bro like
you know what I'm saying I just I didn't
I wish I just wish it you know I just
wish that that didn't have to happen
[Laughter]
all right man that was awesome I don't
know how I'm gonna I don't know how to
follow that up but
unfortunately Ryan
I'm not on your side this time
um listen I do believe that this is
going to be a really good game I think
the spread is probably a little inflated
but because of that spread and knowing
that air exposure doesn't give a I
think
that the Celtics are going to get out to
a pretty considerable lead early they
know they have to jump out early the
home crowd is super important obviously
at TD Garden
but the third quarter is definitely the
quarter that matters the most in this
series if you look at all of the games
these games have been won and lost in
the third
so I'm taking the heat at plus 700 to go
down by at least 10 but win the game I
think that they could go down 10 within
the first
seven eight minutes of the game and then
you have the entire game to watch and
just watch them Chip Away watch Jimmy
Butler do his thing watch Eric Spoelstra
out Coach Joe Missoula and the series
Ends Tonight plus 700 and if you look at
that spread at minus eight it seems like
the sharps and the books are all aligned
that this might get out of hand one way
or the other I think there's value there
in plus 700 you could turn 15 bucks into
120. that's what I'm doing tonight do
the math for them bowling you can turn
50 in the what
150 and uh 1200. is that right I don't
know what it is
out
I haven't done that in so long the only
thing I know about math is how do I
count these parlays and I can't do it
fast enough so I just exposed myself I'd
be terrible at a standardized test right
now
yeah two picks down Ryan
take it away
I I thought that that was great analysis
by both of you it's breaking news our
expulsa doesn't care that the heat are
underdogs that was
unbelievable can you believe that I mean
we posted it right because we posted it
we posted it I don't agree with
everything that we post it's just it's
breaking news
Ryan before it happens before you give
your best bet KJ Mullins in the chat
saying no Scott Foster tonight that's a
big deal what's the MVP last last game
no it's it's Ed Malloy and uh I believe
uh Mark Davis maybe it's yeah the
Celtics record with them is not good
that's what we're gonna we're gonna
ignore it uh it doesn't matter here's
the deal
Celtics minus eight tonight look at
these look at the splits look at the
splits the public
all over Miami the the trend in this
series has been the underdog has not
only covered in every single game the
underdog has one outright in every
single game
and you hear something like that you go
how to how do I not bet the Miami Heat
tonight have a braid for yourself okay
the my the Boston Celtics smoked the
Miami Heat back at home in their own
building they get to come back after
saying don't let us win tonight all this
yada yada yada all this rah-rah stuff
after all this talk about you know Joe
Missoula is he the right man for the
jobs are the Celtics fake like each
other you get to come home it's your
building a building where you lost two
games already in this series
stamp your mark down and say we're going
back to Miami and all the pressures in
the Miami Heat I think they blow them
out tonight uh no Gabe Vincent is huge
the heat are a little bit banged up
there are auxiliary pieces from uh you
know outside of Jimmy did not look great
last game
um I think they've kind of run out a
little bit of confidence and I think you
go back into the garden with the
pressure of we can't let this come back
to us with them getting all the momentum
I'm I do think that Jimmy's probably
gonna put a lot of stuff on his back but
he needs help and I don't know if he's
gonna get that tonight so Celtics minus
eight we're fading the trend and uh
we'll see you guys in Miami
listen I I love I love all the analysis
for sure that's great enough but
I need to ask you one question thank you
do you think you think that the pressure
is really on the heat right now because
I think the pressure's on Boston the
pressure is on Boston to come back home
and finally win a game at home this
series do you think that they're gonna
be a little tight because they didn't
play well there and they haven't played
well they're a lot this playoffs so I
would say the pressure is not on Miami
yet I would agree with you that the
pressure is on the Celtics to win at
home tonight
I just think they get it done I I just
really do I got Ian Evans here in the
chat uh talk to him Ryan uh he both cash
the Celtics money line last so did you
bowling and now all of a sudden you're a
heat guy but hey I do I'm not a heat guy
I just like money dude there was no way
that was that that game four was never
going Miami this way everybody knew that
this is a little different story it's
just all of a sudden I'm gonna see you
sweat in your first baskets with the
Miami Heat hat on and then I'll remember
this okay uh but yeah listen the the
pressure is on the Boston Celtics
tonight for sure uh do I think that they
rise to the occasion I do
pressure makes diamonds you know
pressure burst pipes
um
those who aren't ready for it though
those who aren't ready for we've been
here before we'll take care of business
pressure will definitely make or break
you uh hey
that's the show fellas from Ryan can you
do what you do best one more time for
the people people that just came if
there's a lot of people that just joined
and they want to know what is the parlay
one second one second let me let me
inform some people do you want to go
back to my best bet tab uh Ryan so do I
want to no but will it yeah for H-Town
832 and Cool Hand Luke 777 the bet is
Miami to trail by 10 and to win the game
that is plus 700 on FanDuel so you can
go check that out like I said a little
earlier I think that the Boston Celtics
come out strong they take a 10-point
lead third quarter is the quarter to
watch that's how you get the plus 700.
sorry Greg let me get out the way
[Music]
uh uh can we go to the parlay please
oh there it is
yes I will say this I want to touch on
on bowling's bet for a second year if
you like the Heat tonight I do think
that's the way to bet it I don't know if
at any point a live money line for Miami
is going to touch plus 700. so I will
say if you like Miami I really do I'll
back you up there bowling I do think
that's the way to bet
that's not a good thing when Ryan backs
you up I just just
he knows wow
he type of thing on you bowling don't
don't do nothing I love it I just I'd be
a winner like a cold draft come through
my apartment like some goats just came
in about to disconnect me from the show
dude
one more time please
yes sir Caleb Martin 10 plus points
Jason Tatum six plus rebounds Derek
white 10 plus points and Jimmy buckets
Jimmy Butler 20 plus points four legs
plus 102. we're looking to stay hot
where all this talk that maybe we're not
hot yet because we only won one I think
we're hot you guys can say whatever you
want we're red hot we're red we are hot
we are hot yes we are hot uh
it's time to get on the body here man
I'm ready to go win some money I'm ready
to go win some money I'm ready to go put
these bets in uh my name is Greg ivory
to your left we like to call him
producer Ryan to your right I call them
in B you might call them Michael Bolin
but he is the man of the app uh and we
we about this thing y'all
peace
[Music]
[Applause]